welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Xi Chan an assistant professor at
yale school of public health professor
Chan's research interests involve health
and development economics his work
explores how social interactions affect
health behavior and outcomes and how
socioeconomic status drives social
competition today we'll talk with
Professor Chan about how keeping up with
the Joneses is contributing to poverty
and health problems in China
welcome professor Chen thank you very
much it's my pleasure to be here so
let's start with me
I guess asking you how you came to study
this topic is there anything in
particular that led you to it to be
perfectly honest
is this a this is a combination of luck
and the past dependence so I was trained
as a great culture economist and you
know most of the people in this world
are living in poverty and so if you know
the people are being poor then you know
much of the economics that really
matters and most of the poor people
really rely on agriculture to earn their
living so if you know the economics of
Agriculture then you know much of the
economics of being poor so that's that
was a opening remark by Theodosius in
the 1979 Nobel Prize nectar and I think
it's known as truth today then he was
like 30 more than 30 years ago so that's
I'm lucky to be in the program in the
agricultural economics program and
because I'm I was enrolling the program
I have many chance to go to the field to
talk to farmers so many of the starters
you mentioned it just a few came into my
mind due to my field trip so for example
you mentioned that I'm working
like health behavior especially the
stigmatized behavior I was in the field
in central part of China at that moment
I surveyed the farmers and the talk to
them ask them detailed consumption and
the income and the suddenly I realized
there's a huge gap between the two so
how could they spend so much but without
a very very large income ok so then then
the farmers was very shy they told me
that they also engage in blood cells so
that reminded me of all the literature I
say about the broader market of
stigmatized for example in India there's
a large organs in market and there
there's a stigmatized market associated
with this type of behavior so so that
linked my observation to the large
literature and the secondary you also
mentioned like a gift spending festival
spending so that's also coming into my
mind when I was in the coastal region in
in the suburb of shop out of Shanghai I
I was on a bus and I met migrant worker
who told me that if three of his friends
hold weddings in a single month then he
will run out of the money so that's a
huge burden for them so I was not key to
being a failed survey in western China
another area then I the first day I was
in the field I I ran into a wedding very
luxury wedding went on in that region
and I attended a wedding from that time
on I realize how waste of all those
consumptions could be ok let's talk
specifically about the research that
you've done give us a brief overview of
it you might research is actually and
it's at the intersection of basically
three things a public health development
and the house and the labor economics
those three things are and I have
a lot of interest in doing looking at
how poor people they behave differently
from other other populations and how it
affected their economic and we're being
and how it affected their their health
so for example to highlight some of my
research
the first thing I'm interested in is to
look at how social interactions affected
their behavior so so that's why the
first the first the natural question
coming to my mind is how the social
network can evolve so I'm working with a
PhD still in that you know Economics
Department
to look at more to develop a theoretical
and empirical measures to better improve
the previously previous estimation
measures for for link formation so we we
have more flexible estimation and we
introduced utility function people form
link because they feel is better to form
the knot form so we we introduced such
utility function very classical
economics utility function into the into
the framework and also for the second
area on this gift there and spending
escalation actually I'm linked that to
the large literature of which had the
early development and especially in
neutral people nowadays more and more
realize that the first few months in
utero is very important for their
well-being so we try to test how those
predictions and have on for the children
for a longer period of into their labor
market performance they are we're being
and the work we are doing are quite
different
unlike the natural disasters nuclear
fallout those things I'm looking at a
very basic and every day so that I think
that's a very relevant to the most poor
people so you are and what parts of
China are you looking at
basically my I'm recently looking at at
Western China but also looking more
broadly to other countries so basically
though it is generally the poor
population in agricultural areas okay
yes so these people are engaging in
gift-giving as part of their culture and
they are giving beyond their means
that's what you're finding and that has
a health effect on their children
because they're not getting the
appropriate nutrition probably and are
is there anything else contributing to
that the health issues the part of the
one of the reasons of those type of will
give the giving and is in my research
it's due to the due to the changing
demographics conditions okay for example
the you can say say that nowadays
because of the some preference and the
one-child policy in China some other
countries don't have one child policy
but they have some preference then it
means a lot to the marriage market a lot
of surplus sons were born them women so
that totally shape reshaped the balance
of the marriage market and the sons
family need to throw very luxury
weddings and investing cars housing
stuff using their life savings to to to
invest in those ceremonies so so in the
field we actually find that the groom's
family they organize far more lavish
weddings than gross families they don't
do much of that so that's a demographic
condition not changing the gift-giving
and the ceremony spending and the second
seem important is the inequality issue
in China the the Gini coefficient is the
official rate is passing 0.45 that's a
very anomaly but according to some no
official statistics like some serviced
by universities they show that the Gini
coefficient is more than 0.6 one so
that's really
this means that when the people some
cool people becoming rich they may like
drive up the competition about fodder
for the poor guys and the in China you
know maybe there is no much safety nets
and the same consumption by the poor and
the rich can be in different totally
different things so they want to catch
up but they have very scarce resources
so my while my papers was referenced in
The Economist magazine the the inner
magazine they first talked about how the
rich people they they like seeking
status and they like buy luxury goods in
Paris but then in the second part they
talked about the motives not restricted
to the rich people actually for the poor
they have more incentive to climb social
adders so that's the second thing the
third thing is very concrete is about
remittance in in 2004 China has passed
the very famous Louis turning point that
means that the labourers are becoming
very skills and which rate are driven up
if we look at the gift data we collected
and also the also the the wage
increasing rate you put these two
figures together you will say that they
match very well so that means and in our
rigorous analysis we also find the
remittance also drive up say surprised a
lot of people young people the young
generation they migrate out and they
they send the remittances in cash and in
kind to their parents and the parents
may spend the different way they they
treat this type of income as we know
income so they they are easy come easy
go so so they're disproportionately
spent on ceremonies and we also find
that for families without those type of
window in common remittances this year
there's a spillover effect to those
families if they are in the network of
families with large remittances so these
three things I think the main factors
that driven the escalation of the case
ok so I mean is there any end in sight I
mean how much will this how much can
this possibly progress - it seems
already that it's out of control so what
do you think is going to happen I think
you in the near future you can say more
and more such as spending because the
overall income growth rate is very high
so you still say a lot of resources
being put into this activities but
gradually I think people were job a job
adopt from and they maybe are reluctant
to be dropping out of this like a gift
and step ceremony spending but on the
other hand there are some like social
security program going on and also like
reduce such reliance on the informal
social networks social spending or gifts
for example the recent the recent
implementation of the old-age pension in
China in rural area which covered most
of people and our study now show some
initial results showing that people are
becoming less reliant on the on the gift
spending as an informal way informal way
to ensure against the future risks the
reason is that they with more pension
income they become more economically
independent not only independent from
their adult children but also from the
community where they live okay so so the
gift-giving what is the purpose of the
gift giving to get them some secure
status in society there are many like
motives for example people give gift
just want to insure against the future
risk for example they realized in a few
they want to hold ceremonies they want
to other people to contribute right so
defray some of the costs that's why okay
so you give to others so then down the
road when you need to have something
they'll give to you for your yes that's
basically not changing this thousands of
years that's a very basic form of mutual
insurance what's really worrisome is
about the escalating part right which is
not explained by this cartoon or the
social norm is not changing it evolves
very slowly but some sudden change from
outsider like the sex ratio sings and
and the remittance is like inequality
just the happen in the wrists in the
decades this can totally change the
equilibrant that that make people to
contribute to send more gifts I say okay
well and let's touch back again on the
health concerns the in-utero part
explain that again to me how it's
affecting that particular situation this
is a there's a large literature on this
hypothesis called Parker hypothesis of
film origin hypothesis which shows that
if there's external shocks to the in
Europe Europe this will last long into
future like in the labor market into
like chronic diseases so and especially
in the first semester of the in utero
so in our analysis we can separate the
shocks of social events like weddings
funerals hosted by the fellow villagers
in the in the village so not only not by
them their own household but by other
people around and to show how it affect
the people differently in different the
true masters first the true master
second and a certain master and we look
at some some very where used in the
house indicators like hide for age
because height is very useful indicator
to indicate a long term
and nutritional status and we also look
at a weight with his is more immediate
measures of this and also we link our
findings to the large literature unlike
on diabetes obesity is those issues
because they all predict that a loss of
weight or stunting or wasting they can
predict a long-term loss for example
have higher chance to have diabetes in
the in the early in their later life
okay interesting
okay so I again I just want to come back
to you are arguing that the gift-giving
basically because they're giving so much
money in gifts that women are not eating
enough during pregnancy and that's
affecting the children yes okay so how
moving forward how do you improve upon
that situation do you see any way to
lessen that happening oh this is a good
question so we need to like think about
the policy implication how we can
intervene so but it's really hard but we
can like firstly I think the research
can suggest to the anti-poverty programs
we have a lot of anti-poverty programs
in the world and in South Asia in Africa
but we still say that people like
throwing lavish weddings funerals in
Ghana in South Africa in India they
build empty house but no people live
inside so they just want to show status
in China gift-giving is when impotency
and the bride price and dowry India is
is very huge for those poor families so
we need to think about whether the
traditional or the conventional any
poverty measure program is effective
enough we for the conventional poverty
program they only care about two lifting
people out of poverty by measure of
income but they're not spending much too
much time on looking at
how people spend those money so how
spending this money is really matters to
their we're be so so we so one thing I
think we can like suggest is is to is to
like start a the key players in those
events
now when for example when you have a
network information you know who is the
key player in those social network then
if your targeted key player in those
events then if we're have a spillover
event to generate multiplier effect that
to the people around so that will become
more efficient and even if for some data
I know it's quite costly to collect a
social social network interaction
measures but you still know that in a
community who is the powerful guy who
make decisions usually in my study I
find that those people the the party
leaders the village leaders they they
actually spend more on gifts and they
are very popular to receive gifts from
other people when they host the
ceremonies so if you target those people
without social network information
anywhere peace still be proved to be
very efficient and also we in the in the
long run we we also need to think about
what factors really like change the
equilibrium and not only this network
things for example as I mentioned the
inequality and also the demographic
condition like more men and women in the
labor market if we don't fundamentally
changing this this factors then we we're
still say those gifts of spendings
squeeze out the basically consumption so
we need to fundamentally changing the
Democratic condition changing the way
people spend their remittances and
changing the way people are money and
readership redistribute their wealth
then we can finally
Haeckel this issue it seems like it will
be a difficult issue to tackle
especially because it seems to be so
culturally ingrained in society so
because of that it seems like it's a
very difficult problem to overcome
unfortunately but it sounds like you're
making some progress with it so that's
good okay well thank you for being here
today and sharing some of your work
thank you very much for more information
about professor Chen and his research
please visit our website at Yale edu /
Macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale